DAVID: All right.
I think it is time
to get started.
Thanks everybody for coming.
My name is David [? Multz ?].
I get the privilege
of introducing the two
founders of Ninkasi Brewery.
We have Jamie and Nikos.
So thank you guys
for joining us today.
NIKOS RIDGE: Thanks
for having us.
DAVID: So, yeah, let's
do a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
To kick it off, everybody
look under your seat.
There are five golden coins
that have been shot up
to space and back, and you
might be the lucky recipient.
If it's not under
yours, please do not
go through all the other seats
right now, we can do a later.
AUDIENCE: Is it
physically attached?
DAVID: It is
physically attached--
taped to the underneath.
Hopefully there's--
NIKOS RIDGE: They were used
as ballast for the rocket.
So we made commemorative
coins to use instead
of just straight weights.
DAVID: Has anyone found one?
Or it was an April Fools' joke.
JAMIE FLOYD: Yeah,
we're just see-
you're checking to see
if there's gum under any
of those seats for Google.
So we appreciate
keeping it tidy.
DAVID: Great.
All right.
Well, we'll talk
about that later.
We also have trivia at
the very end of this,
so pay attention to the
talk because there might
be some prizes coming later.
So all right, so
let's start us out.
Ninkasi Brewery-- what
does Ninkasi mean?
NIKOS RIDGE: So Ninkasi
was the ancient Sumerian
goddess of fermentation.
So Sumerians were
the first culture
that we know of
that brewed beer.
And they worshipped
different gods and goddesses,
and Ninkasi was the
goddess they worshipped
for what-- at the
time-- they believed
was the miraculous
process of fermentation.
And if you want to get
really deep into it,
it's even speculated that
beer and fermentation were
part of the reason
that they settled
into a sort of more
stable agrarian society--
so a foundational
element in beer.
JAMIE FLOYD: Yeah, just to add
to that-- the oldest living
recipe in human existence
is the prayer of Ninkasi,
which is an explanation of
not just a praise of her,
but an explanation
of how beer was made.
And it's an important aspect
that we like to point out
is that beer is food.
We're kind of lucky
as a civilization not
to have to count on
that all the time,
and so a lot of times
people chuckle at that.
But beer originally
served as a way
to unleash nutrients from grains
that were not understood better
at the time as far as how to get
nutrients out of cereal grains,
and also made for potable water,
which is why we didn't have
to hunt and gather anymore.
DAVID: Very cool.
And expanding on
that, can you give us
a background of your
brewery, how it came to be,
how you two met, et cetera?
JAMIE FLOYD: Sure.
I'll start just real quick
to give some background
because I'm the founding
brewer-- part of the situation
that-- I started brewing when
I was 17 years old as a college
student.
And it was one of the
nerdy sort of side projects
I did, and hobbies.
And when I graduated
from college
I had a sociology degree.
And I got a job
pretty much right
afterwards as a kitchen
manager of a brewpub in Eugene
called Steelhead.
And I was just paying some
college bills and sort
of sorting myself out
when, about a year later, I
got asked to be an assistant
brewer at Steelhead.
And that's when I realized that
my dream of being an educator,
opening my own business,
and supporting our community
could come real
through making beer.
And I spent 11
years at Steelhead
building the skill sets that
I needed to start Ninkasi.
At which point, I took the
leap and decided to leave.
And Nikos and I were
actually acquaintances
through a mutual friend
who works with us
and does-- all the
amazing tap handles
and metal artwork we do
it's inspired by him.
And basically, Nikos
actually applied
to be my assistant brewer
when he moved back to Eugene.
And--
DAVID: Not hired.
JAMIE FLOYD: Not hired.
I was quitting and
I didn't really
actually want to hire the people
that were going to replace it
because they were
hoping to work with me
and I knew I was quitting.
But I put that little seed
in the back of the head.
And one fateful day after work,
we were all at the Bier Stein,
a local bottle store in Eugene.
And Nikos and our
friend [? Jaz ?]
asked me what I'd do if
I ever started a brewery.
And I sort of ranted
on at a time which
I wasn't telling
anybody because I
would have been fired
from my company right away
and all that stuff.
But it kind of started that
inspiration-- the spark
started there.
And Nikos and I got together and
started working on the project.
And we open doors in 2006.
July 1, 2006 is was we
count as our birthday,
and have done quite a bit
in nine years almost here.
DAVID: Very cool.
And what was the first
beer you guys brewed?
NIKOS RIDGE: First beer we
made was Total Domination
IPA, the beer you're
drinking right now.
So it was at a time when it
wasn't as common to have IPAs
everywhere like we have today.
It's definitely caught
on as the top beer
style in the craft industry.
But at that time,
there are very few that
were commercially available
from packaging breweries.
And so it had been a beer style
that Jamie had been making
for a long time at Steelhead.
And it was the first beer that
we wanted to make as Ninkasi.
JAMIE FLOYD: Yeah.
And IPA was the second
style of beer I ever made.
I made a stout first with my
long-term homebrewing friend,
Russ, and then
started IPAs as well.
IPAs have been coming
out of the Pacific
Northwest since the early
'90s, just like San Diego.
DAVID: Very cool.
And so you guys
are based Eugene,
distribute all over Oregon,
we see here in California.
Can you talk about
your distribution?
Like what's your biggest market?
Where did you start?
And go from there?
NIKOS RIDGE: Sure.
We started just in Eugene.
And we self-distributed
our products there.
And we still self-distribute
And then we just
sort of expanded out,
concentrically more or less.
And still Oregon and
the Pacific Northwest
are our biggest markets.
In Oregon now, Portland,
as a single market,
is our biggest single market.
But definitely now, spreading
into some new territories.
We're excited for
the opportunities
that we have in California, and
now Arizona, Nevada, and Utah,
Idaho--
JAMIE FLOYD: Colorado.
NIKOS RIDGE: Colorado.
JAMIE FLOYD: Alaska.
NIKOS RIDGE: Alaska,
British Columbia.
So--
JAMIE FLOYD: [INAUDIBLE].
NIKOS RIDGE: Yup.
DAVID: Very cool.
And according to
RateBeer, there's
almost 200 breweries
and brewpubs in Oregon.
So how do you compete with
so many breweries around you?
JAMIE FLOYD: A lot of the craft
beer movement changed shortly
after we started.
And we're not trying to take
credit for all that change,
although we made some decisions
early on that certainly helped
a lot of other
breweries sort of get
into the market
in a different way
as far as taking some risks
with some distribution,
and really supporting some folks
that were trying to come up
themselves in that range.
But a lot of it for us
is we did get kind of
out in front kind of early on.
I'd also started brewing
at a really young age.
And we got into the business
in 1995, which was still
relatively young at that point.
Steelhead was the number 10
brewery in the state of Oregon.
And as you say now, just
nine years-- well, excuse me,
more like 15 years later,
there's almost 200.
So we got in front
of that a little bit.
Because of that as well,
we were able to get
a good chunk of
market share upfront,
and really provided
opportunities
for other breweries to get int
and compete against us, which
has always been fine with us.
And I also started, as part
of getting the skill sets
needed to open my own
brewery, I started early
on serving as a board member
of the Oregon Brewers Guild,
and really spent a lot of
time networking with everybody
in the industry as much
as I possibly could.
So I was the first president
of the Oregon Brewers Guild
that wasn't an
owner of a brewery,
and sort of was look at as one
of those up-and-coming young
leaders, and represented
sort of the small brewery.
It's changed a little
bit, obviously,
with us being the
third largest as far
as sales for Oregonians--
brewers in Oregon.
But we still lead
with that leadership.
And I spend a lot of time in
the homebrewing community.
And so people know us to
be real and authentic,
which is an important
part of who we are.
And I think that that
really helps the cause.
I mean, there's still
going to be some haters
out there in the world.
And whether it's jealousy
or just not knowing us,
or whatever it is.
We just keep plugging
along and be friendly.
And a lot of the
principles that we do,
we work a lot of with
the Brewers Association
and another trades to really
help support other breweries
as they come up.
I spend time on the Brewers
Association technical committee
and helping create the
quality subcommittee.
Because with now upwards
of 3,700 breweries,
and when we started I think--
what was there, 1,100 maybe?
NIKOS RIDGE: 1,600, I think.
JAMIE FLOYD: 1,600
when we started.
So 2,000 breweries have
started in the last nine years.
So there's going to be quite a
difference in level of quality
out there.
And those of us that
have been in the industry
don't want to see
other breweries have
to make some of the
mistakes that some people
have made as they grew.
And we're really concerned
about the total flavor profile.
I think it's definitely
a branch of crap that's
different than the old
sort of school of brewing
with fierce competitiveness
and hatred of each other.
You don't hear as many people
who worked at Budweiser for 20
years jump over to Miller,
as you seen breweries
within the craft community
jump around like that.
NIKOS RIDGE: Yeah, it's still a
really collaborative industry,
which is a great thing.
It makes it a lot of fun.
JAMIE FLOYD: Lots
of collaboration.
DAVID: Absolutely.
And so we're actually here today
to talk about their new beer.
So we will open with a video.
VOICEOVER: Mars--
T-minus 30 seconds.
The vehicle is armed.
CROWD: Three, two, one.
VOICEOVER: Fire.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
VOICEOVER: We're going
to [INAUDIBLE] first.
CROWD: Yeah!
DAVID: Wow.
So you decided to
send yeast into space
and create a space
beer-- the first ever.
And you called it
Ground Control.
So can you talk about how you
got the crazy idea to do that?
JAMIE FLOYD: Yeah, I had--
about two years ago--
the really wonderful
sort of happenstance
of a mutual friend,
someone who works
with our wholesale
distributorship up in Portland,
who knows some of the
amateur rocket enthusiasts
that we worked with
on the first mission.
And at an even I
was doing, Chip,
who was a part of Team Hyperdyne
came, and brought his computer,
and sat down with me, and
started to show me past rocket
missions, part of what was
going on, explained the program.
And I grew up with a very
serious determination to be
an astronaut, and not sort of
just in the boys', I want to be
an astronaut sort of stance.
I was really prepared to join
the Navy, and be an officer,
and become a pilot, and go
through the whole program,
and say I'd be willing
to strap to a rocket
and get launched into space
and see what happened.
And obviously, I chose a
different lifestyle and course.
But I'm still a nerd.
Most people that
know me know that my
love Star Wars, and sci-fi,
and space, and astronomy
in general.
So I was obviously
really intrigued.
John, he was there, said
it was the first time
he's been-- and
still to this day--
that I've been to an event in
which I was kind of blowing
everybody else off at the event
because I was just too focused
on the nerdydom at hand.
About six months later,
they re-approached us.
They were looking,
obviously, for support
for an amateur launch where it
didn't have government support.
Thankfully, Nikos
is as nerdy as I
am and loves the creative spirit
of the frontier-ship and sort
of who we are as humans.
And we kind of got involved.
We support lots
of awesome things,
and I don't necessarily
participate in a deeper way.
But we sort of were like, well,
if we're going to do this,
let's do something.
And what we decided to do
so that really in the end
we be closer to the
whole process was,
let's try to send yeast
to space and create
the environment and the controls
that are there so that we can
defy the gravitational
challenges,
and the extreme G-Forces of
leaving Earth's atmosphere,
the extreme cold of space,
the solar radiation that's
emitted outside of our
atmosphere that were protected
from, and then, of course,
the intense heat of return.
And that took a lot of work,
and obviously, two tries.
And that's kind of the
approach that we took.
So it just sort
of came together.
It was the right
rhythm and feel.
And it kind of comes down to
when Chip asked our friend
John, hey, we thought about
talking to a brewery, what
would you do?
And he said, oh,
there's only one brewery
that I could think of that
could possibly want to do this.
Maybe that's a stretch
in terms of I'm
sure there's some other people
that wish they could do it,
but we recognized
the opportunity
to be part of
something that was way
outside of our general
sphere and something
as exciting as what turned out.
So it's been really awesome.
DAVID: Very cool.
Yeah, I was reading
online, and a lot of people
are super excited.
It's a crazy brand new idea.
But then there
were some skeptics
that were kind of questioning,
like is there really
a benefit to doing this?
Or is it a way to
sell more beer?
So how do you
respond when people
ask these sort of questions.
NIKOS RIDGE: There's really no
good reason to do what we did.
I mean, I guess I have
to be like, I agree.
Yeah.
But it was a really fun
and exciting adventure.
It was a lot harder
than I thought
it was going to be when
we first were like, yeah,
that sounds great.
Let's make it happen.
It took a lot--
yeah, two missions,
and a lot of involvement,
and a lot of energy.
But it was really,
really cool to learn
about what was going on, kind of
be in a fringe area of science
like that.
I mean, rocketry, especially
at the amateur level
or the sort of non-governmental
level, is-- it's really hard.
And it's something that is
really cool to see people
that they're so into it
that they can actually
make it happen.
And watching something
launch into space
is also a lot more visceral
than you might think
if you haven't seen it happen.
I thought it would
be cool to see.
But actually being there for
it was really, really awesome.
JAMIE FLOYD: Yeah.
I like to use the
example of most people
turn on the TV at night, and
then probably at least one
out of the five TV
shows they really
like is based on a spaceship
where people are cruising
around and beaming
themselves everywhere,
and just having normal
conversationss-- let's
go to the mess hall
and hang out and stuff.
And really, this process
really brought it home.
I mean, you can
really-- empirically,
we know that that's
not the case.
But the reality is, we're way
behind the gun of anything
close to that.
And every space mission is
fraught with the potential
of failure.
And everything about it is
contingent upon calculating
everything precisely, and making
sure that nothing went wrong,
and making sure the
weather is right,
and making sure there isn't
a satellite in the way,
and just all kinds
of amazing stuff.
And so it was really
meaningful for us
to be a part of
something where we
could see the real
intensity of what it takes
to put something into space.
For me, it's a lifetime
sort of value for me
just to experience watching it.
I mean, it really does.
If you watch-- people
watch fireworks and all
that, but there is
something just primordial,
which sounds weird,
but it just takes
you all the way to
the sort of soul level
when you watch just
how crazy we are
that we decided at some point we
would try to just bail gravity.
It was pretty--
kind of put us back
for a while when we first
realized what gravity was.
We were like, well
I guess that's it.
But with airplanes
and then other things
now, we're crazy enough
as a human populous
to just really take that
exploration further.
DAVID: Very cool.
And so why did you decide
to make an imperial stout
verse other styles you could
have made with that yeast?
And then, how did you decide
on the name, Ground Control.
JAMIE FLOYD: As far
as the beer goes,
we really wanted to
create-- this is a really
special project, and we really
wanted to create something
to back it all the way up.
And so we wanted to make a beer
that would-- with the artwork
and with the story, it's surely
going to be a collectible item.
And so it is going to
get put into cellars.
So we didn't to brew
like a blonde ale,
or like American standard
light lager, or something
that would be not that
drinkable four months later.
So we wanted to brew a
beer that was like that.
We've made a number
of imperial stouts,
and we want to make something
that was unique to itself.
I mean, you can make a
lot of different stouts
and a lot of different IPAs.
So we sourced some
local hazelnuts
that were grown in Oregon.
And we got some cocoa nibs from
a chocolate creator in Seattle,
and then star anise that
we were able to get locally
from an herb wildcrafter
that was there.
So we decided to create sort
of a desert-oriented imperial
stout that would
cellar well and sort of
be worth the total value
and price of the excitement
of the rest of the experience.
And of course, we used
Apollo and Comet and--
NIKOS RIDGE: Bravo.
JAMIE FLOYD: And
Bravo hops in it.
And we kind of--
NIKOS RIDGE: Tied
it all together.
JAMIE FLOYD: We
tied as much of it
as we could together into
a beer that we thought--
and of course, space
is pretty dark.
It's black and dark and
heavy in a really light way.
NIKOS RIDGE: And the name
Ground Control-- obviously, it
relates to space and relates to
launching rockets and all that.
And we had a lot
of different names.
And it's actually
kind of the way
you have to name beers
these days in the craft beer
industry.
Because really with 3,000
plus, 3,500 breweries,
there's a lot of names that
are already in use out there.
So you kind of make a list of
names that you'd like to use,
and then you kind of go through
that list, and narrow it down,
and then you look and see
which ones have or have not
been used, and go from there.
So we were happy that we
were able to find something
that we can relate to the
process of launching--
DAVID: Very cool.
JAMIE FLOYD: Yeah, and we also
have a huge tie to music as far
as our brewing culture goes.
We have a recording
studio inside our brewery,
and actually work with a lot of
bands, and do a lot of music.
So obviously, the
"Major Tom" sort
of ground control reference
too is part of it as well.
So it has that old sort
of '70s retro feel to it,
which I think really goes
in line with the space
program as a whole.
DAVID: Right.
And so a lot of
people in the room
are wondering where
they can pick it up.
Are you distributing
to local-- like BevMo!,
Whole Foods-- what's your
distribution looking like?
NIKOS RIDGE: So it's pretty
limited in it's production.
But it will be available
throughout our territory.
And not exactly sure
yet every location.
And it won't be
broadly distributed.
But a lot of specialty bottle
shops and specialty beer
retailers will be getting
it through our network.
So I would say check those
out, and call around,
and see where it's at.
Or you can call the brewery.
Or you can check on our
Beer Finder on the website
and see where it's
being delivered to.
JAMIE FLOYD: Yeah, either
through the Beer Finder,
or if you contact us,
then we can put you
in touch with our team down
here and they can sort of
share that with you.
So we do think that,
given it's limited supply,
that it can go away
pretty quickly,
so definitely want
to search it out.
DAVID: Nice.
And speaking of that--
are you planning
on making more, doing this
again and making another style
of beer with the yeast?
Or is this a one-time thing?
NIKOS RIDGE: Well, we were
able to-- the first time,
we sent up 16 test
tubes of yeast
and it took 27 days
to find the rocket.
And we had built the
conditions to keep the yeast
alive for about 12 hours.
They had two tracking
devices that failed.
So it took a long time.
And at that 12th hour, it
was actually 108 degrees out
at the Black Rock Desert.
So we knew that the yeast was
not going to totally survive.
And they came back-- there were
some cells that were alive,
but not enough to rejuvenate.
And we learned a lot
from the process.
The second time, we sent six
different test tubes of yeast
up.
It had three different
strains involved.
And we were able to get
four test tubes back
that were viable with three
different yeast strains.
So we use our house ale strain
to create Ground Control.
We have a lager strain
that we use for the Lux--
those of you that had
Lux, we sent that yeast
to space and back.
And then we have an alt
strain that we use in Slayer
and some of the other beers.
So we have the potential
to culture up and continue
to do this a little
bit here and there.
And then one of the
other things that we
plan to do down the road
is to release the yeast
to some of the yeast banks
that are out there that
want to be able to
maybe get it out
into the hands of
homebrewers and other stuff.
We're not trying to be the
proprietary owner too long
over the whole deal.
Of course we want to
do our run with it,
but we even have one
of our-- we're actually
really good friends with
the crew over at Falling Sky
Brewery, which is a
much smaller brewery.
But they make all their
own foods and stuff there.
And their baker, who I used to
cook with a million years ago,
requested to see if
he could get the yeast
to do a sourdough starter even.
So like we said earlier,
we're a sharing community.
So we want to-- it's
about sharing the yeast,
but it's also about
inspiring the imaginations--
just the creativity in brewing.
I mean, there is
a similarity kind
of with that fringiness
you were talking
about between the extreme
passion of a homebrewer
over versus someone who's an
amateur rocket enthusiast.
The only difference is the
amateur rocket enthusiastic
gets to watch it go down
about once every two years,
versus every weekend
or when you have time.
DAVID: Right.
And going through this whole
process, what sort of lessons
have you learned on
doing such an expedition?
Like, rather than
just brewing a beer
and distributing,
doing this whole
phased approach of a major
initiative, a marketing
strategy, et cetera.
NIKOS RIDGE: I'd say, yeah.
I think, tying to
Jamie's point, I
can kind of see things out
there that make you think that,
oh yeah, we've been
to space forever.
It's easy.
It's something we're going
to set out and do it.
And I think that's kind
of normally the experience
that you have-- at least
that I've had generally
in my day-to-day life.
You kind of do things that
are kind of tried and true.
And yeah, we started a brewery.
But there's a
mechanism for that.
And there's distribution.
And there's a pathway
to success there,
and you can make that happen.
So getting involved with
something that was not so
cut and dry, and then actually
failing the first time
around-- because I
mean, honestly, I
went into it thinking,
oh, well these guys know
what they're doing.
We'll get the yeast in
there, we'll get it up there,
we'll get it back, we'll make
the beer-- nice and clean.
And then it was definitely
this roller coaster
through the whole thing of
being involved and doing
all these activities with
the teams to make it happen.
And then not having
it work out, and then
trying to figure
out what to do next.
So I guess the lesson for
me was more in the idea
that there's a lot of
really cool things going on
out there that we're
not able to just do
whenever we want to do them.
And so that's a good
lesson to keep in mind.
You'd got to keep
pushing the envelope,
and taking things
out to the edge.
And it's a different place
to be when you're there.
DAVID: Right.
JAMIE FLOYD: Yeah.
One of the things
that I learned is
that you have to--
even if you think
you know your supply
for something,
that you have to
check ahead of time.
The second launch happened
at Spaceport in New Mexico.
We were staying in
Truth Or Consequences,
which is a funny name.
I don't know why it's not
True And Consequences.
But it's still a
really cool spot.
And we needed to use dry
ice to pack around the test
tubes so that when
it was reentering,
that that intense heat
could be on the outside
and protect the yeast.
First, the second
launch-- the first day
that the launch was supposed
to happen, the weather was bad.
So they postponed it, like
you hear a lot on television.
They're not going to send a
rocket up into a lightning
storm, which is good.
But we had to come
back a few days later.
And James, who's in
our marketing team,
came back with me.
He was a part of the
first launch site
and was willing to come with me.
And we checked
into our hotel, we
were going to go eat some food.
And then go get
the last supplies
that we needed at the Walmart
that was there in town.
And in the three days
that we weren't there--
because we had been there and
check the dry ice supply--
hunting season started.
And a group of hunters
came in and bought all
of the dry ice that was there.
All of it.
Not a single drop.
And we discovered that
at 10:30 at night.
And we were supposed to
meet the rocketeers at 3:00
in the morning to be able to
load our part of the rocket
before NASA and some of the
other scientists showed up.
And it just shows the
ingenuity that it takes,
and the sort of
struggle that goes
on with all of this stuff
in that we basically call--
I think we made 40 phone calls.
We realized that
most of the Walmarts
around that area did not have
dry ice anymore-- the Roth's
chain-- or, the Smith's
chain, excuse me, had it.
But they closed at 11.
We were 10:30 at night, and
we were at least 45 minutes
from the closest one.
So things got kind of crazy.
And we'd put a lot of
time and resources.
And so I basically went back
to Walmart, just my typical,
I don't fail, not going to fail.
And was trying to look for
chemical cold packs or anything
that probably still wouldn't
work, but just anything
for me not to feel like a loser.
And the general manager's like,
oh, there's a new [INAUDIBLE]--
I mean, there's a new
Walmart over in Alamogordo,
which is 165 miles away
from where we were.
So James and I popped into
the convertible Camaro
that we had rented for our
Thelma and Louise moment
together, and took off
into the desert at midnight
to drive all the way around
White Sands Missile Range
to get to the Texas border,
basically, to buy dry ice
and get back.
And we were able to move
our stuffing time to 4 AM.
But that included
two border patrols,
in which I had to tell
boarder police that we
had dry ice in the
trunk because we
were trying to
pack a rocket that
was being launched into space.
And what was so awesome about
it is that they believed us
because they work next
to White Sands Missile
Range, where rockets happen.
So learn that that is
part of the human spirit,
that we don't quit, we
just look for options.
And I'm really glad
James was there.
That would have been
a real tough gig
by myself-- or for anybody
to do by themselves.
But through that creative
spirit and just not giving up,
you can achieve a lot.
And it really does equate to
a deeper satisfaction to it.
So when people ask us how much
submission costs, and does
it have a payback,
and all that stuff.
I mean, I have a lifetime of
total memories and satisfaction
from being a part of
it, and really getting
to know these people who've
dedicated their entire lives
to this and don't get the
share this with many people
more than once.
I mean, they have different
clients that come in and out.
And they might know some
colleagues and stuff.
But they're kind of out
there in the fringe.
And it's wonderful to see people
that just love what they do
as much as we love what we do.
And I think that that's a
really heavy lesson for me, is,
we all do what we love, and
especially if we're lucky.
And to the degree that we
can share those experiences
with each other, we can really
bolster each other up and help
us see new perspectives.
And it's an experience
that I'll never forget.
NIKOS RIDGE: And
I don't know what
it is about rocket
launches, but that's
the second time we stayed up all
night before a rocket launch.
The first time, we actually
were driving around
in the Black Rock Desert,
which, if you've been out there,
you can basically drive
and drive and not stop.
JAMIE FLOYD: It's where the
Burning Man project happened.
NIKOS RIDGE: Because
it's totally flat.
And we ended up
getting lost, and then
ended up having to also be
at the rocket launch at 4 AM.
So we ended up just
staying up all night
and waiting for the launch.
JAMIE FLOYD: And it was two
days after the supermoon.
So it was a pretty amazing
night on the Playa.
And we were doing a little
roof surfing and we got lost.
So it was a good night thought.
DAVID: Very cool.
So we have a few more
questions by request.
And then we're going
to open up to Q&A.
So one of the first
questions was canning.
So traditionally it's
been a lot of macrobrews
that have canned beers.
And it's been associated
with cheaper beers.
And now there's a movement that
a lot of the craft breweries
are starting to can their
beers-- it's lighter,
it doesn't allow
as much light in.
Can you talk about that?
Is that something you
guys would consider?
Or--
NIKOS RIDGE: Yeah, I
think it's definitely
we'd consider for
us at our scale
and with our focus on quality.
It's just a pretty
big investment
to move into a whole
new packaging line.
And we just actually
built a new brewery,
so we're sort of working to
get that filled up first.
But it's not off the table.
It's probably not
something that's
going to happen in
the next few years.
But it's definitely a direction
that the industry's moving
and there's a lot of great
beer out there in cans now.
JAMIE FLOYD: Yeah.
Living in Oregon, there's
a lot of outdoor pursuits--
not that there isn't in
California or whatnot.
But so most of us are hikers,
or hikers, or kayakers,
or outdoor pursuits.
So the can has
that benefit to it,
but our bottling line
is capable of doing
a lot more than our
annual production will
reach for a long time.
So we're rather focusing to
upgrade and make that system
better than to add a new one.
When we started, we had
to use a mobile bottler.
And then we bought a
small, similar machine.
And then we had to use the
mobile bottler in our cells
to keep up.
And the variance in quality
just doesn't meet the standards
that we're at now.
And so for a lot of people
that are starting out,
they may be using mobile
canning devices, or people
come in and can it for them, or
buy smaller machines and stuff
like that.
And we've just really
reached that level
where we task ourselves too hard
to want to put ourselves back.
Why would we sell
a canned beer that
isn't going to have
the same shelf life
as a bottled beer of our own.
But to Nikos' point, it's
definitely not off the shelf.
It's just sometimes Nikos
and I are a lot more patient
than our fans want us to be
about some of the things.
DAVID: All right.
And so you mentioned
Total Domination's an IPA.
You mentioned all the
IPAs that are nowadays.
It seems like that's been
the recent trend, IPAs.
Do you see that staying
here for a while?
Or what do you think is the
next big trend in craft beer?
NIKOS RIDGE: I think so.
I mean, IPAs are delicious.
And I still drink
more IPAs myself,
or IPA style beers
than anything else.
But I view our brewery sort
of as a microcosm possibly
of future beer drinking
trends, because we, as brewers,
drink in dog years.
So one year at a brewery is
like seven years of regular--
JAMIE FLOYD: Drinking.
NIKOS RIDGE: Drinking out there.
Volumetric guide.
So starting to see a lot of
people internally starting
to move into some of the
lager beers and lighter beers
that we're making now just as
a nice sort of easy drinking,
sessionable, kind
of classic beer.
And if you look to kind
of developed brewing
regions in Europe and
things like that, I mean,
they've kind of
historically gravitated also
in the lager direction.
So I'm guessing that IPAs
will always be there to stay.
And then there's going to
be some other beers that
also start to sort of take up
another portion of the drinking
experience for people.
JAMIE FLOYD: Yeah.
I think that we're really
fortunate in Oregon.
50% of the beer that's consumed
in Oregon is craft brewed.
And 40% of that-- or, excuse
me, 40% percent on draft.
That's specifically in the
Portland and Eugene areas
for the most part, which
still make up over 2/3
of the population.
So that's a pretty amazing
achievement for a small state.
And that's really where
the world is going.
And to Nikos' point, we live it.
It's kind of a natural part.
It's not hard for us to find.
It's everywhere.
And a six pack of Lux
or a lighter lager
is just as happy next
to an IPA six pack
when you're heading
to a barbecue.
I think people
are less specific.
Yes, I'm a total hophead.
I've been using
hops my whole life.
I love it.
But I also fell in love
with brewing because
of imports like German lagers.
And it's always been an
important part of who I am.
And I think as
other demographics--
ex-military, people
who have spent time
in Europe in their formative
years serving the military,
they all discover beer.
Their love of beer is
centered around things
like Bavarian beers, and
other styles of beers
than we're familiar with as
young beer drinkers in the US.
And so as those
demographics open up,
we're creating products
that please them.
So it's not about trying
to get the vet who
wishes they could drink
a helles to love IPA,
it's about making them a helles.
And I heard some other things
about whether-- is sour beer
one of the next things?
Yes, in the terms
that it's a trend.
But does it have
long-term marketability?
Is it something
that-- ask yourself,
do you think about drinking
a gallon of vinegar
every time you
sit down to drink?
I mean, it does similar
things to your body.
So again, it's a complement.
Someday we'll start
doing some sour beers.
We're looking at doing a
Berliner Weisse style beer,
which is a lot easier to do.
But we're really patient.
So we're not as attached
to that end prize.
And I'm not sure that
people that-- unless you
have a smart business
plan, that people that
focus on more esoteric
styles as their core brand,
they'll have to see
how beneficial it is.
There's been a
definite resurgence
of creativity in terms of the
ingredients used in beers.
And so a lot of the cool stuff
being thrown in beer that maybe
people didn't think about.
And I think that that really
comes to the authenticity
piece.
So if the consumer
thinks that it's
a great idea for real and
not just something cheesy
and marketable, then that's
where trends can start
and stuff like that.
But I think that's
the real deal.
The future trends
of beer are going
to be more about the
beer itself and what
goes behind it and the
breweries that do it
than the specific beer or
gimmick that might be there
for some other
breweries as well.
DAVID: Great.
And then last
question for me is,
so you mentioned 2,000 new
breweries have opened up
over the years.
And there's almost
500 in California.
Do you think the beer
market is saturated?
Do you think it's a bubble?
Just more and more
keep opening up.
NIKOS RIDGE: Yeah, I don't
think it's saturated, for sure.
I mean, the craft consumption
in the United States
still under 20% of
total beer consumed.
There's a lot of
opportunity there.
I think like any
bubble scenario--
there might be people
getting into the industry
right now that maybe think it's
easier than it is because it
has been a growing industry,
or maybe coming into it
for different reasons than
wanting to make great beer,
and put in all the work that
it takes to get to that point.
So I think we'll definitely get
to a point where some of that
will kind of work itself
out of the system.
And I know you guys have
probably never seen anything
like that in tech.
But yeah, I think there's a
lot of room for a lot more beer
to be made in the United
States as people start
and continue to move
into drinking craft.
JAMIE FLOYD: Yeah.
I had a technical committee
meeting earlier this week
for the Brewers Association.
And one of the members of
the Brewers Association
said that there is
900 and, I think,
56 breweries in planning
currently in the United States.
So we're about to go 25%
more than we currently are.
So the reality of it is it's
like a restaurant or anything
else.
Restaurants have a one in
three chance of survival.
I think, depending on
what your goals are,
breweries have a good
chance of survival.
But if you're a homebrewer
that doesn't really
have a lot of experience
in owning a restaurant,
or selling alcohol, or
knowing the industry
and your goal is to see your
beer on a Safeway shelf,
it's going to be a tough
ride because there's
a lot obstacles in the
way of that goal based
on what your experience or
maybe your resources are.
But say you're a homebrewer
that's worked in a restaurant,
your family owned a
restaurant, and you
want to open a little
local brewpub that
allows for your neighborhood
to come and really support you,
and most of your
beer is sold on sight
so you're not behoven to
wholesale or distribution
chains, chain acquisitions
over large stores.
It just all depends.
Some people are prepared for
one style, and one for another.
The craft beer industry is huge.
James in our
marketing department,
that I mentioned before, said
one of my favorite things,
which is that craft beer is one
of the last punk rock movements
left the United States.
And I think a lot
of that has to do
with the amount of government
regulation that we have,
that there's a certain
aspect to who we are that has
to be a very specific way.
But outside of
that, we're really
open in a way that
original American spirit
entrepreneurship or
capitalism, whatever you want,
in which people get to be
themselves and really create
business plans that are
marketed towards their passions
and drives.
And I think that the
more that people resonate
with the stories and the
qualities of the beers
that are made, then the
more that that story
keeps perpetuating itself.
So there's going to
be a continuance.
And I don't think it's much the
chagrin of some of the larger
breweries in the world.
It's not going to
go back that way.
Those macrobreweries
had prohibition
on their side, in which
there were, I think,
20 years, 15 years before
prohibition there were 3,000
breweries in the United States.
Right before prohibition,
it had been reduced to 1,000
through what we see these days,
of conglomerations and people
buying each other out.
But when it came back, a
lot of breweries flourished
and a dramatic few
wrangled them all up
and created a
pretty small amount,
and basically
created the culture
that drinking beer in
the US means one thing,
and it's our beer.
And the difference is
between our branding
and the subtle differences
in the ingredients we use
is the difference between beer.
And we're just a
different culture now.
Millennials don't care
what their parents drank.
And that's just a reality.
My dad spent seven years in
the Air Force, almost six of it
in Alaska.
He drank a lot of Rainier
and played a lot of cards,
and he, back then,
smoked cigarettes.
And I think of that.
My uncle drank Coors when he
made steaks in the backyard.
And I have resonance
with that as a kid.
But I also own a brewery.
So of course it's going
to have resonance to me.
But for the young drinking
community, and the people
as they come of age and decide
to get involved with beer,
they have different desires.
And it's going to be really
difficult for the macro world
to sort of take that out.
So as long as we all love
creativity and craft beer
and sort of that
sense of independence,
it's going to go a long way.
And I really hope that
craft beer continues
to market itself that way.
Because Sam Adams
isn't even the largest
US owned brewery because
it's publicly traded.
So we don't really know even
what percentage of ownership
is-- or at least I don't.
I'm sure they do.
But we're the last
US owned breweries.
And the more that we get behind
that and think in that terms,
the more that it's a
success for everybody.
DAVID: Great.
So we have time for
three audience questions.
So if three people want
to come to the microphone
right here if you don't
mind and ask a question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
It's been really
interesting to hear
you talk about your brewery.
I was wondering how many
different kinds of beer
are you brewing at any
given point in time?
And is it a continuous process?
So you're constantly
canning-- brewing and canning
and brewing and canning.
Or do you take
breaks in between?
NIKOS RIDGE: We
brew 24 hours a day
when we're brewing
within a given week,
but it's not seven days a week.
It depends on the brew
schedule for that week.
And typically between 7 and
12 beers going at a time.
And then throughout the year,
maybe 20 and 25 total beers,
depending on special projects
and single batch beers
and things like that.
So we have a variety of
different things at a given
point-- yeast management,
different strains, all
that stuff plays into it.
We have a pretty flexible team
and a pretty flexible brewery
setup.
So it allows us to be creative
and do a lot of things
throughout the year.
JAMIE FLOYD: And we
have two brewhouses.
So neither one of the brewhouses
is functioning all week long.
So we split the
batchings between it
to keep for efficiency's sake.
Although we were playing a
little bit with some of that.
But in general, we do
have two brewhouses.
So in addition to 24 hours
for a limited time period,
it's also separated between two
brewhouses across the street
from each other.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So you spent-- so
the yeast to space,
which is really cool--
I mean, we all-- I
think we all would love to
do such a similar thing.
But is there anything
different about the yeast?
Did it mutate from all the
extra radiation in space?
Or is there anything-- I
mean, you make a lot of beer.
So do you taste anything
different about this yeast
than the yeast
before it went up?
Or is it just like, it's fun
because it went to space.
JAMIE FLOYD: Well, I mean, to be
clear, the goal of the project
was to send the yeast up
and have it back the same.
As scientists, what we do
when we propagate yeast,
we're not trying
to create mutants.
We're not trying to turn
people into lizard alien folks
when they drink our beer.
NIKOS RIDGE: That'd be sweet.
JAMIE FLOYD: I
mean, it's be fun.
That would be cool.
But what we did do when we
got the yeast up and back is
that we made a batch
of IPA-- the beer
that we make that
makes up 50% to 55%
of what we make in a
given period of time.
But we took a batch of that and
we diverted some of the wort
that we made into a separate,
basically 10 gallon, homebrew
batch size.
And we had cropped up
the yeast and made beer
with the same wort, with yeast
in space, yeast that we had
so that we could check on it.
And it was the same,
as far as that goes.
I will say though, that second
ride was a cold one for it.
And the yeast was actually
cryogenic in a way.
It froze while it
was up in space.
And it worked.
But it was a big trip and it
took a little culturing up.
So to that degree, the
yeast tastes the same,
but it took a lot of work to
get it back when it came back.
AUDIENCE: How high did it go
and how long was it up there?
JAMIE FLOYD: That's
a good question.
AUDIENCE: It was
suborbital, right?
NIKOS RIDGE: 77 miles--
yup, suborbital.
So 77 miles and about four
minutes outside of the--
JAMIE FLOYD: Yeah, so a 15
minute rocket cycle basically,
where it launches up, spends
about four minutes in space,
and then it takes
a good 10 minutes
to get back between the
different levels of return
so it slows down and doesn't
hit at maximum impact.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
DAVID: Great.
And last audience question.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Yeah, sorry-- two
quick questions.
So one, what do you make of
the trend in hard ciders?
And two, are you doing
anything about the drought?
Or has the drought affected you?
NIKOS RIDGE: Hard
ciders are great.
It seems to be growing.
And I think there's a
lot of cider drinkers.
I'm excited.
We have a couple new
cideries in our area
that are focusing on more
traditional European styles
of cider, which are
a little dryer, which
I'm not a big sweet cider fan.
So I think that's
going to continue.
I think it's a great, sort
of new, creative avenue
for a lot of people.
And then-- second question?
AUDIENCE: About the drought.
NIKOS RIDGE: Oh, the drought.
So Oregon has less snow
pack than a lot of years,
but where we live,
in Eugene, we're
fortunate to have access to
consistent and one of the best,
actually, water sources in
the country via the Cascade
Range and the McKenzie River.
And so Oregon's
topography and geology
are different than California.
So even if we don't get snow,
our ground's a lot more porous.
So we get a lot more
collection, versus the granite
you guys have here, which
if you don't get snow
that it runs directly
out into the ocean.
So where we're at
in Oregon, we're
really fortunate to have access
to a consistent and future
supply of water.
But it is going to be a
challenge for the industry
in a lot of places
and so it's definitely
a topical question in the
conversation that's going on.
JAMIE FLOYD: Yeah.
To follow up with that.
I used to make
cider at Steelhead.
And we actually have
a winery license.
And we'll make a little bit
of cider on-site to honor that
and to be able to sell
a little bit of cider
at our tasting room.
It's sort of a
gluten free option.
We work with some of
the local cideries
already to have
cider for people who
visit that are in that state.
But I will say with
the cider boom,
new apple trees take five
years to produce fruit.
So with the huge run of
what's going on in cider,
your access to apples
is very limited.
So I'm currently working
with a farmer, who
is local in Eugene,
who has a press
and is looking for a place
to sell his apples in a very
direct way, which is what I used
to have back in the Steelhead
days with a farm whose owner
sold the farm basically.
But we've now found
a new source to be
able to do a little of that.
But I don't really-- well,
every input good into a brewery
is a commodity.
And getting into the apple trade
would be a pretty hard thing
right now.
And then--
NIKOS RIDGE: The drought.
JAMIE FLOYD: The drought.
Well, we're making a lot
more beer for you guys
in preparation-- I think
is a good way to put it.
But we're very
concerned for that.
Nikos and I are not interested
in building breweries
on the East Coast
or the Midwest.
And we've seen some
of our older friends
step up and do those
sorts of things.
And I will say, I got to
give them a little credit
for-- I wouldn't have
thought about a big drought
and being told that you had
to produce 25% than last year.
They can put that into capacity
in their new facilities
that have had, in some cases,
really giant snow years.
So I don't know if that was part
of their plan, but good on them
because they're going to
be less effected than some
of the other breweries
that are local.
DAVID: Great.
So we have a few
trivia questions.
If you win trivia, you
get a poster from John.
So let's see who was
paying attention.
You don't have to go to the
mic, you can just shout it out.
JAMIE FLOYD: Can I just
talk about that real quick--
about the poster?
DAVID: Oh, yeah.
JAMIE FLOYD: Neil
Williams is what
we call a gig artists, in
which he does concert posters.
He's worked with Dave
Matthews, and, boy,
Interpol, Trombone Shorty,
Galactic-- all kinds of bands.
And he recently moved
to Eugene and worked
on the project for us-- for
all the artwork that's here.
So these are all hand screen
printed by the artist.
And they also glow in the dark
because we're rad like that.
And anyway, I just wanted
to give a little plug
to the artwork because
that's another fun
and giant piece of
this whole project
was putting it all
together that way.
There it is, Vanna White.
DAVID: Oh yes.
So feel free to shout it out.
You don't have to go to
a microphone this time.
What does Ninkasi mean?
AUDIENCE: The Sumerian
goddess of fermentation.
DAVID: Yes.
Yes.
JAMIE FLOYD: All right.
NIKOS RIDGE: Nice.
DAVID: Perfect.
All right.
At what altitude did
the rocket go to?
How high did it go?
AUDIENCE: 77 miles.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
NIKOS RIDGE: Recollect.
JAMIE FLOYD: All right.
DAVID: What are-- I guess
we didn't talk about this,
but what are the four
ingredients of beer?
AUDIENCE: Water, hops, yeast,
and barely-- or some sort
of multigrain.
DAVID: There we go.
NIKOS RIDGE: Nailed it.
JAMIE FLOYD: Nailed it.
If you'd just stand up
and come down to grab it--
DAVID: Oh yeah.
JAMIE FLOYD: It's over here.
DAVID: What style of
beer is Ground Control.
AUDIENCE: Imperial stout.
DAVID: Right there.
JAMIE FLOYD: Good
moderation here.
DAVID: What were the--
just yell out one.
What was one of the three hop
varieties in Ground Control?
AUDIENCE: Appollo--
AUDIENCE: Comet--
AUDIENCE: Bravo--
AUDIENCE: Appollo.
DAVID: Yep.
Three.
Yes?
NIKOS RIDGE: Yeah.
DAVID: If you yelled
one of those out,
feel free to raise your hand.
I lost you guys.
How many employees does
Ninkasi Brewery currently have?
We didn't talk about this,
but if you're within 5 to 10,
you get--
AUDIENCE: 105.
DAVID: Yes.
Wow.
NIKOS RIDGE: Nailed it.
JAMIE FLOYD: It's 106,
so you're right on there.
Actually, 107.
You're hired.
No, just kidding.
DAVID: And then, last
questions-- two part question.
What are the two
byproducts of fermentation?
We did not talk
about that either.
AUDIENCE: Space--
AUDIENCE: CO2 and alcohol--
AUDIENCE: CO2--
AUDIENCE: Alcohol.
DAVID: CO2 and alcohol.
Someone said space,
which is awesome.
All right.
That's it.
If everybody could give a
round of applause to our--
NIKOS RIDGE: Thank you
everybody for coming.
JAMIE FLOYD: Thanks
for coming out.
DAVID: And I believe
everyone gets to try
Ground Control on the way out.
So as you're walking
out, feel free to give
a taste of Ground Control.
Thank you guys for coming.
NIKOS RIDGE: Thank
you for having us.
Thanks a lot.